hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well at the very
beginning of his book language truth and
logic in the first page of the first
chapter here is going to say that part
of his project here is to engage in a
critique of metaphysics that is
criticizing the metaphysical thesis that
philosophy affords us a knowledge of a
reality transcending the world of
science and common sense and that's a
very nice succinct formulation of what's
going on in the rest of the work what
the main project of this book is it's to
try to say that that philosophy whatever
philosophy is going to be must
essentially be confined within the
phenomenal world that the natural and
Social Sciences can engage with or that
our ordinary common sense can make sense
of an approach an heir says that his
project is indeed indebted to him to
David Hume as well as some other more
recent empiricists and indeed some of
the positivist as well but he's going to
contrast his project quite usefully with
another major philosopher who engaged
in a critique indeed a set of critiques
of the possibility of metaphysics a
metaphysics that would transcend the
realm of experience as we know it here
in in this tangible perceivable and
scientifically tractable world and that
is Immanuel Kant so air begins by saying
we're going to critique this
metaphysical thesis that philosophy
affords us this knowledge and he says
later on when we come to define
metaphysics and account for its
existence we shall find it as possible
to be a metaphysician without believing
a transcendent reality but it's
convenient to take the case of those who
do believe it's possible they have
knowledge of a transcendent reality for
our discussion now what does he mean by
a transcendent reality something that
goes beyond that trans kid over a write
in Latin something that goes beyond this
this realm of phenomenal experience so
if somebody says well I believe that
there is a spirit running throughout the
entirety of the universe you so that's
cool show me that spirit well you can't
really see it as such you have to you
feel it or we can we can reason our way
to it or things like that that's exactly
what air has in mind as a metaphysics
that is transcending the realm of
experience a transcendent reality so he
says there's a couple ways of attacking
this one way is to inquire from what
premises his propositions were to do so
you say ok you're you're you're making
these claims what's your basis for these
claims can you can you set out your line
of reasoning or evidence for me and if
you do I'd better see some empirical
propositions in there otherwise I'm you
know I'm not going to be that effective
in figuring out how you got from A to B
so he says must this person not begin as
other people do with the evidence of
their senses
if so what valid process of reasoning
can possibly lead to the conception of a
transcendent reality how can you get
from empirical that is experiential
propositions beyond that to something
that goes far beyond the empirical
reality how can you get propositions
about a transcendent reality says surely
from empirical premises nothing
whatsoever concerning the properties or
even the existence of anything super
empirical can legitimately be inferred
and there is one way out of this that he
notes and many people were doing this in
air zone times as a matter of fact
there's still people doing it today and
there were people doing it in Kant's own
time and they would say something well
actually in humans time as well they
would say you know we're not basing it
on our senses were endowed with the
Faculty of intellectual intuition
there's some way in which were able to
intuit
to grasp what transcends empirical
reality and so that he goes on he says
even if it could be shown that they were
relying on empirical premises and the
venture into a non empirical world was
therefore logically unjustified it
wouldn't actually follow the assertions
he made concerning this non empirical
world could not be true so you can't
overthrow a system of transcended
metaphysics merely by criticizing the
way it comes into being and here's where
we get Ayers declaration of his own
project what is required is rather a
criticism of the nature of the actual
statements which comprise it so let's
take a pause there for a second think
about this he's saying that if you want
to understand whether it's possible to
go from empirical propositions things
about the world things that we can agree
on like this is at rock board and
there's white writing on it or or
anything along those lines to something
that's not empirical that's transcendent
that's as we would typically say
metaphysical if you want to do that you
need to look at the language of those
propositions
and maybe look at the processes of
inference as well but it's the language
itself that affords err what he thinks
is the fundamental clue to how to
resolve these sorts of difficulties here
he's going to as I was mentioning
contrast his point of view and his
method here against that of the great
thinker Immanuel Kant who is doing
something kind of similar who's making
somewhat similar claims about the
possibility of metaphysics so he says
Kant condemned transcendent metaphysics
but he did on different grounds and so
err a little bit later we'll say that
Cantus is rejecting the possibility of
transcendent metaphysics but he's doing
so as a matter of fact he's saying
listen you just can't get there from
here
we found all sorts of problems when we
try to do that sort of thing not that
there isn't a transcendent metaphysic in
some sense you just can't do it as a
human being
air is saying that no this is actually
an impossibility as a matter of logic a
matter of the way in which language has
to work so how does this work so let's
take a look at the Conte's
Kant said the human understanding was so
constituted that it lost itself in
contradictions when it ventured out
beyond the limits of possible experience
and attempted to deal with things in
themselves so the things in themselves
there beyond the phenomenal realm the
experiential realm they do exist or at
least we have to postulate that they
exist Khan says but we can't get at them
through philosophy and and when or let
alone science or any any other sort of
thing and when we do that because of the
way our minds are constituted we wind up
in all sorts of contradictions or
sometimes he says and enemies and so you
know if you want to see where this this
happens take a look at the prolegomena
to any future metaphysics and also take
a look at the first
critique but you'll also see some
discussion of this in the last part the
groundwork for the metaphysics of morals
and in the second critique as well but
it is primarily coming from the first
critique so the human understanding the
way that it works you just can't get a
transcendent metaphysics that doesn't
have all sorts of contradictions not
that you couldn't have a transcendent
metaphysics per se just we can't because
we go beyond the limits of our
experience and that's where we can you
know make sense of things but there's
still this you know thing in itself out
there and this led to that you know the
vast development of German idealism and
the issue of limits so he says that you
know Vidkun stein says in order to draw
a limit to thinking we should have to
think both sides of this limit a truth
to which Bradley gives a special twist
in maintaining that the man who is ready
to prove that metaphysics is Impossibles
of brother brother metaphysician if you
err went back a little bit further
Bradley was a British idealist which
meant he was drawing upon hegel hegel
explicitly discusses this in his science
of logic the problem of the limit in
thinking the limit you're already
thinking beyond the limits
so the content project kind of falls
apart it doesn't work the way that they
want it to work ear says I'm gonna go
more radical I'm gonna look at the
language itself so by focusing he says
on the literal significance of language
of metaphysical statements for example I
can show that the you can't go beyond
possible sense experience he says the
fruitlessness of attempting to transcend
the limits of possible sense experience
will be deduced not from a psychological
hypothesis concerning the constitution
of the human mind a LeConte or post
conscience right but from the rule which
determines the literal significance of
language what is that rule that is going
to be what he calls the criterion of
verifiability which
the central part of this this works so
he says our charge against the meta
physician is not that they attempt to
employ the understanding in a field
where it cannot go but that they produce
sentences which fail to conform to the
conditions under which alone a sentence
can be literally significant he says we
aren't obliged to talk nonsense in order
to show that all sentences of a certain
type are necessarily devoid of literal
significance we only have to formulate
this criterion and then we can show that
all of these metaphysical statements are
strictly speaking nonsensical at least
on a literal level and that's the thing
that he's interested in here so this is
really in some respect what we call a
transcendental critique showing the
conditions of the possibility of
ensuring also by contrast that something
else is impossible by showing you know
these these conditions what would it
take for language to actually make sense
or convey meaning verifiability
according to to air so he's shifting the
ground from you could say an
intellectual or psychological basis that
he says Kant has got to a linguistic
basis and this is really a central
feature of ayres linguistically based
philosophy
you